I wanna ask Peter brand and that a new
game he reviewed we're back review
season at Resident Evil zero HD remaster
I guess the latest remastering of
President people 00 is not like the
original remake of the original resident
evil because Rick Resident Evil the
original was remade for Gamecube it was
and then they remastered that for HD
Resident Evil 0 unless you discount the
nintendo 64 prototype that was made
right it was made for the gamecube and
then remastered for the wii it wasn't
remastered for them it wasn't me rest
for the way they just ported it and they
added new control ok that doesn't count
so it didn't look better known as a
little bit better that's no okay so this
is as far as you're concerned this is
the ultimate the only remastering of
Resident Evil 0 yes that's going at this
year who cares for online Capcom but
it'll be fun I got a bunch of questions
are from the users on gangs but I'm
gonna ask you about your review I've got
a couple of questions myself as well
first of all AB is this game it's only
like 20 bucks or something I saw it on
steam it was only like twenty bucks oh
it's a nice game that sounds right you
can buy it as a bundle with the remake
of the original reading right for the
remaster the original remake for forty
dollars so at some windows you played on
xbox one right yes also on PlayStation 4
did the 360 and ps3 versions are they
coming as well another uh when I looked
at the product listing last time it did
so that indicate yes but I don't have
those games in hand yeah I've played
them no worries and I want to talk to a
Wesker mode before because no one asked
about Wes commode escamoles is the funny
like it's literally nothing to do Rob
Lee with the game but I just loved um
bonus modes for video games yeah so you
can play this entire game is all the
Wesker but it doesn't change his voice
acting no so it just replaces the
character model of Billy yeah Billy cut
everyone's favorite resident evil
character Billy yeah the tank tops
slick-haired so yeah replaces him with
Wesker and Billy's lines are just stupid
to begin with yeah and and wesker is
kind of a odd being himself so it's kind
of nice to finally see him like utter
lines that are really silly and own it
because in context it's really weird to
have Wesker having someone else
voice quite as well yeah but more
importantly so he's like super powered
he can use guns he doesn't have a
limited health mmm but he can he has the
ability to uh no without limits release
these bursts of energy that decapitate
zombies bra and you can like hold the
button down and charge it up so you
decapitate zombies that are that far
away from you okay yeah you can also run
really really fast right knock over
areas look BAM head explodes great yeah
so this is he's running super fast that
looks like like a broken automation I
know and that's just it is like so much
of this mode is is unbalanced right um
and that's fun is it for speedrunning
that or something or it's for
speedrunning I also think it's kind of
cathartic cuz i sat down and played
reasonable zero from start to finish the
day before writing this review um and at
the end of that I was very exhausted
because that was like ten it's like 12
hours yeah you know tense survival like
all this stuff and then it starts me off
again I'm like okay I have to try Wesker
mode but then I'm just like tearing
through zombies like nothing's great and
all of a sudden I feel like game is new
again all this stress is gone it's just
about fun and I really like it it's good
good bonus mode I like it why I wanted
to give some sort of a card shy you know
ahead of time to that because I like
dumb bonus mode I miss Chi Chi miss
things like that's like a mod you did it
for Skyrim or something so so let's talk
about resin he was here then how do you
when you were before I get to the sort
of user questions how do you review game
like this because do you review it based
on the fact like this technical exercise
of oh this is a remaster of an old game
so how good does this recapture what
that old game was or do you have to
review it as a game that came out you
know whatever over ten years ago and how
does it play in 2016 like how do you
balance that sort of aspect well it's an
old game and therefore you have to
acknowledge the things that are a
product of the time but you know you
could say o people can just read the old
review and then we can just write
something about the technical
improvements right but a person today
their tastes are probably very different
from someone who's reviewing the game
back then context is everything in these
cases somebody who's playing it
somebody's playing imagine a teenager
playing this in you know they weren't
too maybe even a kid who's like 12 right
who was not alive when the game came out
you know in that sense you have to
review the game for what it is and you
can't really make apologies for things
that are old I think it's fair to point
out why things are the way they are yeah
but get a lot of comments people saying
like Disney understand when this game
came out like bubble I was like yes I
played it when it came out I understand
that but I'm playing it today as someone
at 2016 and some things are not that
great and those need to be taken into
account and no apologies right yeah I
seven out of 10 on guess what so it's a
good game excellent Abby Gary one asks
seeing as the pc version has 60 frames
per second option and the ps4 and xbox
one doesn't Are you disappointed do you
think it would have been does a benefit
at all I don't think it matters it
didn't matter to me I mean less I'm
playing like an arcade shmup or heaven
forbid ever get into league of legends
or I'm playing street fighter right yeah
60 frames per second isn't necessarily
that important especially do a game like
resident evil is about to say it's quite
cinematic so yes even the lower frame
rate like lends itself to a more
cinematic presentation and you know on
consoles they lock it to 30 probably
because they wanted to use the extra
head room for better lighting and
shadows all right and I'm pc they
probably unlocked it for 60 because pc
gamers just want to be able to do that
yeah you know they want to see the
number and feel great about and do
themselves yeah that's true that's
something we come across with making
video stuff a lot as well as that like
60 frames a second is something like 4
gameplay like I feel like that's
something they like to do a lot but for
instance like Andy are you is this 30 or
23 Ron you don't know you're not
shooting is 60 frames like so like this
one here is probably on 30 right so like
if we go to Andy single whenever we do
this for the point it's always like
super low yeah I don't know am I wrong
that kind of looks like Tibet 24 is it
it might be being upscale that we don't
know it's been good for NT for a while
and it made it look like there were
little live mannequins yes I'd of
YouTube it was kind of creepy nice like
I like a second for a second for like
ninety-five percent of games but yeah
there are some situations in which it
just it actually kind of takes away from
the experience like weird uncanny valley
for some reason yeah when we tried doing
that on YouTube yeah not a fun I think
we focus too much on whether a game is
TP 60 and not right behind maybe why it
is or is not its kind of shorthand for a
does this game look and play fluidly or
these I feel like that's what it was
meant to be but now it's just turned
into this abstract silly well
because there's so many discussions like
the Xbox one can't do 1080p sixties
right well no it could if the developers
like tone down some of the special
effects in the game it's not like
everything is built on top of kin the
system do a certain frame rated
resolution that's the that's the result
of everything they've decided to put
into the game and I think people should
actually the discussion should be I want
this game at 60s so they should have
toned down the textures it should have
done this right right rather than just
being like I want it all blankly the end
result isn't what I wanted to be
regardless of why all right well to that
end I probably talk too much about
resolution than frames right so let's
get some more gameplay question spike
spiegel ask a question made me laugh at
laugh because this is kind of how I feel
about it did three master make this game
any less boring asking for a friend
wesker mode made it less boring ok i
will say that all right it's does it
what does it feel like when you played
resident evil zero the first time it
does yeah I mean especially because when
you know nostalgia makes everything seem
better right so I'm not coming out this
like wow this looks so much better like
it looks really good it looked really
good to me back when it came out so less
boring maybe only if you beat it and
unlock that extra mode ok oh you've done
lock it to you oh yeah you do do you
have to do anything specifics one like I
just played a game I played it on normal
difficulty I saved whatever I wanted to
add a couple times so yes no
restrictions I got a question here from
savage road and I think this might have
been Twitter I might have been gamespot
comments I forgot everyone says Ida
management is a bad thing in survival
horror game I don't understand that
that's the part of survival in survival
horror and how does that sort of effect
Resident Evil 0 is there much of that
like balancing the amount of stuff do
you convey re-ink ribbons although that
that's the whole challenge is keeping
track of enough items to like defend and
heal yourself while also leaving room
for key items you need to solve puzzles
and weapons because it's all sort of in
one big pool but this game makes it
easier because in other resin Evil games
you had to go to designated storage
chests so if you forgot something I was
like [ __ ] I need to go slog all the way
back there now you can leave items in
any room and the map system is really
good about telling you where you left
something in what it is and you can
exchange items between characters that
said it is a little silly sometimes
because you'll pick up
things that maybe don't go on your
inventory is sort of like a lower item
and there's no limit how much lower you
can carry it as a limited amount of
Laura I can read right you know but it's
like it's weird been like a key takes up
the same amount of space as some
something even like a handgun or like a
bunch of like grenade munitions yeah
it's like that it's a bit imbalance so
it seems silly but the conceit fits what
the game is trying to be and it is this
puzzle of you know having things you
need to survive and then also being able
to progress through the game yeah
interesting i spend all weekend playing
the long dark which is basically a game
is only that's about having like
infantry management and weight
consumption so I think you know in
depending on the game I guess it it
either works or it doesn't and that's
kind of all the questions of what we've
happened to people the folks on gamespot
com and then reaching out over Twitter
and so I guess your final thoughts on a
Peter this is a it's a solid remake of a
decent Resident Evil game it sounds like
yeah like if you want like old-school
survival horror and you don't mind
playing a game that's like got fixed
cameras mmm go for it it's not as good
as the first one but it's still all
right awesome there you go thanks very
much Peter appreciate you coming on
talking about it and let us know what
you think of resident evil HD Resident
Evil 0 HD remaster and in the comments
below let us know are you interested
picking it up would you picked it up it
was a full price game actually I mention
it here that and do you think you'll get
it because it's around the 20 books
limits let us know in the comments below
and in the chat as well on the chats
here thanks everyone for tuning in at
the moment on ksl com on twitch.tv
forward slash gamespot and to our folks
watching on YouTube gaming as well super
appreciated